the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler
Ryan sickler and Ryan sickler on all
your social media I want to start this
episode like I start them all with
saying thank you thank you for whether
you're new here whether you've been here
thank you for supporting this channel
thank you for supporting this show uh
subscribe all that good stuff guys and
if you got to have more then you got to
have the patreon it's called the
Honeydew with yall and it is the wildest
it's the wildest show on patreon I put
it up against anybody else's show
because it's your stories and nobody's
got stories like y'all all right you can
get that you get the Honeydew it day
early you get it ad free at no
additional cost make sure you're
checking out the new show the way back
it's all your favorite guest in
podcasting we've got a ton of them
banked that's every Thursday right here
on this YouTube channel and if you're
looking for a new podcast to listen to
I'm telling you you got to listen to The
Crab Feast that the podcast has been
dead over five years okay it did over
1.1 million downloads last year thank
you for that and I'm telling you again
everybody you know and love and
podcasting except for today's guest
apparently who I don't know how the hell
we didn't get him on there but different
stories all love it all right so um
dates ransler decom that's the biz you
guys know what we're doing over here
we're highlighting the low lights always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers and I'm very excited to
have this guest on first time on the
Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Chad Daniels welcome to the
honey thank you thank you so much from
the Twin Cities bro that's right listen
we don't even need to sugarcoat it thank
you for your patience we've had 40
minutes of uh technical difficulties
which is I'm sorry it's the first time
we ever had that thank you for your
patience I've enjoyed sitting here and
talking well I like looking at all the
pictures in yeah so I got to see every
single one of them twice that's a lot of
them that's
good Chad Daniels welcome uh before we
get into it please plug promote
everything and anything you would like
well socials is that Chad Daniels
because there's a uh kid named Chad
Daniels in the Bay Area that beats me to
everything you prick and uh he won't
give it back no no he won't I've asked
uh so yeah and then chadd daniels.com
tour for all my tour dates I got a real
big one coming up I'm just finishing up
uh this one and then it starts again so
I don't ever take a break you know it's
like this is all I do so people are like
when are you going back on tour I was
like back on tour [__] I've been on
tour for 25 years so well 20 you don't
ever take a break I I I take the Summers
off I guess but it's never you know like
a huge break to start a new hour it's
just whenever I'm at that spot when
summer hits that's it because I go up to
Northern Minnesota enjoy the lakes and
relax all right yeah so I know you and I
um talked for your you did an epic
special back uh what about three years
ago maybe during the pandemic wasn't it
yeah I don't know if we need to call it
a special I don't know how special those
were but
anyways people like to toss that turn
term around quite a bit and it's like
special in this I know that um but I got
to talk to you a little bit and really
get to know more about you there but um
I would like to talk to you here because
you have an interesting story that
resonates with me but uh before we get
into it you originally are you born and
raised Minnesota yeah Fergus Falls
Minnesota born and raised so
until uh February I lived um you know a
mile and a half away from the hospital
in which I was born so just till this
year yeah oh wow so you stayed local the
whole time you never lived here or
anywhere else New York I I lived in
Minneapolis and then and um I guess I
was away from Fergus Falls for maybe 10
years total but when I had both the kids
we moved back up my ex-wife is from
there too and we were like well let's
get everybody closer to family and yeah
so then I've been there raising the kids
and as soon as my daughter went to
college I was like catch you later 15
minutes out of here yeah that's where
you went yeah so what's uh growing up
like got Mom and Dad but um I know
things shift for you a little bit what
but before we get there tell me what's
dad do what's mom do mom is when I'm
real young she's a a teller at a bank
and then she old
school yeah yes
exactly uh then she became uh she worked
at a power company so she was the person
that you would go give your uh bills to
pay the bills to and she was wonderful
right people would come in they'd say
hey I can't pay this month and she'd be
like well it's winter let's figure
something out I mean she would never
send those
to collection because she didn't want
people to have their electricity off so
she's a great woman now as she's gotten
older she's reposted some [__] on
Facebook where I've been like where's
the bill
lady where's the woman who loves
everybody why don't you quit sharing
your friends nonsense so so that has
that's been a bit much it's been a shift
in the well I I I went to her door once
and I'm like the is going on with you
with this Facebook thing she started
crying I'm like that's not going to work
for me I have a teenage daughter you
think I haven't seen tears before enough
and so she was like yeah I know I I just
you know I I want my friend I go n if I
said that to you when I was a teenager
you'd have smack me so don't think about
it wow all right so uh but but great
great great woman all in all um her
parents were around quite a bit like
almost always when when my sister and I
would get dropped off so my parents
could have a weekend cuz they had us
they had me when I was 19 W timeout they
had me when they were 19 gotta that'd be
pretty cool if I came out as a
19-year-old like God damn it I've been
there driving Jesus Christ voted just
voted kicking and kicking let me out
[__] so pretty
ridiculous just born an instant adult
like get the out of here good oh God
you're kicking me out already I just got
here well you're 19 get the out of here
so uh so when they were 19 so they still
had life to live so we'd end up at my
grandparents quite a bit and that was my
my mom's parents my dad's
parents um when my dad was
two his they had a he had a sister so
his sister was born when he was two and
then his dad split he was a over like
Long Haul trucker okay and he took off
he's like this is too much for me two
kids the second one's too much and then
his mom had a mental breakdown and so
then he grew up with his grandparents he
was raised by his grandparents which is
kind of weird because now we're talking
about the the mid-50s right and you're
looking back at now a
generation he's being raised by two
generations ago which is wild to think
about because mid-50s you're a little
kid um you know things are starting to
happen but these old ass grandparents
knew none of it and so that's kind of a
weird time I think to grow up but so
that was that and they grew up in the
same town Northern Minnesota about an
hour away from where I grew up um they
were both great athletes my dad was a um
my mom and dad were both two sport
athletes yeah what' your mom play she
played volleyball and basketball is she
tall she's not no no all right no but
she was uh Setter just real good real
real athletic and then my dad played uh
football and baseball so you've had
extended family all around you for
forever then yeah okay yep it's been
nice and I think that's why we ended up
bringing the the kids back closer to
their grandparents because it's just how
we grew up yeah and are your um well
we'll talk about your dad a minute your
mom she's a great a really good grandom
yep yeah yep good yeah still around
still lives she lives three she goes and
sees the kids hangs out she lives three
blocks away from blocks no wonder you so
you walked over to get yeah yeah have to
drive it's like I'm going to take the
dog for a walk and go scream at your
stupid
grandmother that's nice that's nice
guess what when people storm the capital
it's pretty similar to storm and Target
isn't it maybe we don't need to think
one of them's awesome and the other one
is hurtful Target's a pretty big
Corporation oh so
funny so then what's your do your
parents stay together or do they split
they are they stayed together until I
was 15 okay but even as a child you're
just like oh these two should not this
is like they're hanging on for dear life
and are they arguing or just not around
each other like what I just remembered a
very interesting um so first of all I
remember witnessing a couple things my
dad for my mom's birthday one year
brought her to go watch softball games
wait you're say it again my for my mom's
birthday she was like what are we going
to do do you have anything planned and
he brought us all to go watch softball
games not professional just
like right just like random softball
games and I
remember he so weird I know he just took
you to random softball games like this
is what we're going to do we're going to
watch these people play yeah and I was
10 years old and I because we just moved
into this house and I
remember he called my mom thunder
thighs and I was 10 and I was like dude
uh-uh you like what am I going to do
right yeah I'm like just yell at him and
just waiting for the hand to go under my
chin that was his big move to like quiet
you and so I was like well here it comes
that was what he said to shut up a hand
under the chin that yeah so he would he
would take me like under here and just
put my the back of my head against the
wall not hard not like through it just
like that was that was the we're we're
done talking that was this is your final
war yeah so you know cut to me figuring
out what I like in the bedroom and uh
this poor woman chokes me and I'm like
your [__] hands off my neck right
now this poor woman chokes me do you not
like that like I don't know what's going
on but cry I don't not supposed to talk
but I need to tell you this stuff
so yeah dude it was it I just started
going to this uh MN R it's called it's
basically reflexology and the nervous
system and
everything and she was like uh she
grabbed my wrist and she would pull to
see how my you know my arms would extend
and she goes well your arms are a little
tight you're a little guarded and like
oh am I huh I mean I've been grabbed by
the bicep over 10,000 times in my life
so anytime an arm goes towards my arms
I'm just like suck it in so um he called
her thunder thighs I'm like well happy
birthday this seems great birthday just
so you know I know he called you thunder
thighs but we are going to watch
softball I mean what a stupid ass God
damn it so what's your what's your
relationship like with him the first 15
years of your life um f i mean besides
the this is how you stop talking and
this is whatever um it was fine I mean
he taught me how to mow along to make
sure the stripes were right he taught me
how how'd he teach you it's uh you go
you go one one pass to give yourself
space to rotate it and then you go now
it's down and back no none of this
optical illusion [__] where from
above it looks like you're falling into
something it's down and back down and
back and then did he tell you after
because I learned this one too then you
next time you go the opposite way that's
supposed to like really cut the yard oh
I didn't when I used have to cut grass
they make us go this way and then next
time I come back to like now go this way
I'm like all right all right you guys
got your ways M like checkerboard it
well saying against I see what you're
saying yeah it doesn't look checkerboard
cuz it's grown back now but now we cut
this way every time so now we're going
to go cut it a whole different way yeah
I remember I had we had one of those uh
metal window well things for like a
basement window and I was trying to get
as close as I could with the lawnmower
and the blade hit it and nicked it and
I'm like well this is uh suppose I
should get my Affairs in order cuz I
think I'm about to die I mean it's like
you handed me this [__] machine with
a I'm a kid put gas in it I think about
it all the time and it's like and and
you didn't think something like this was
going to happen you know the fact that
like my little sister hasn't been run
over is incredible so were you guys just
hustling I'm going to ask you this real
quick were you just hustling like
shoveling snow and stuff was that a big
job for you guys growing up like we were
outdoor stuff yeah yeah just going and
cleaning neighbors driveways and [__]
for Miss missan or whatever yep trying
to just make you know you'd get $20 $20
where the you grow up I'm saying that
now I'm
like yeah I'm like five or six or three
that's what they throw you yeah you
shovel and you go and then you know
they'd call they'd call my parents be
like can you send Chad over to shovel
and then I'd go shove I remember there's
one lady Dorothy shoveled her out right
like she was a shut in shoveled her out
sidewalks driveways back patios so she
could go smoke all that stuff brought me
some lemonade and I'm
like I'm like
[__] can you at least take the ice out
it's the middle of winter can you heat
up this lemonade or
Sal unbelievable okay back to your wait
I do have one more question I wrote it
down here because I think about this a
lot did you ever or do you ever remember
seeing your parents affectionate hug
kiss one another at all hold a hand yeah
I remember uh that they kissed when when
we're like okay this is coming to an end
right trying to explain to my sister
our parents aren't going to be married
anymore whatever and they kissed
underneath the mistletoe during
Christmas at my grandparents house and
my sister looked at me like hey maybe
and I'm like don't do it don't get your
hopes up kid that kind of stuff so it
wasn't a ton I did hear my dad once so I
have a girlfriend now and she is like uh
sometimes she be like why don't you how
come you never you know approach me and
try to like woo me into the bedroom I'm
like well I don't know if you're feeling
it I don't know I the thing that I would
hate most on planet Earth is for a woman
that I love to just take it as a womanly
Duty you know you know that [__] happens
all the
time and I would not be able to handle
that if they're just like well I did
that for you well [__] that's gross I
agree I don't get off on any of that
like unless you're into it I'm not into
it exct care what it is I don't care how
much I like it including sex if you're
not into it I'm not into it yeah of
course so so I'm just not into that [__]
and uh and I was talking about it and
then I go oh I remember this thing I our
basement was being redone and so my
sister and I had to sleep in the living
room on the couches and then my parents
would stay up and watch television in
the same room and then I remember my dad
once said um my my mom said something
she got mad at him she yelled at him she
goes enough and then my dad goes if you
don't have sex with me tonight I'm not
going to your parents house this weekend
you heard that and you're a little kid
and you're like I know what all that
stuff is and this is horrible and then
the worst thing about it is then he was
there at my grandparents and so I'm like
you guys [__] that's disgusting bagged
my mom bro yeah in in a weird forceful
way and so I just that has turned me off
to the idea of even if even if my
girlfriend was
like Hey I don't feel great right now
but we haven't seen each other in a
while I'd really love to do this for
every like there's no chance in hell I'm
doing that and I know maybe that I don't
know that puts me in some category in
the big book of you know mental stuff
but I don't know I can't handle it I'm
with you on that I'm totally with you on
that you got to be into it yeah yeah I
don't that's like taking somebody to a
[__] football game like you you
[__] believe this game like it's all
right you know yeah like I don't want
you there you know when I don't want a
blow job on my birthday because this
seems like an act of
service no thank you
yeah all right so you and your dad now
your dad your parents split it you're 15
yep and what happens when they split you
go with Mom do you go with Dad what
happens went went with mom dad lived
about a mile from Mom's and saw him I'm
gonna guess twice a year so it's very
strange a mile yeah I hear this so it's
so funny I hear it from so many people
about my mom did the same thing she
moved a m was like a mile and a half
away and was like nah that's your mom
did yeah my mom this is flipped okay
Mine mine's flipped my dad dies at 16
but just before that my mom was like I'm
out and she bounced and moved I mean
right down the [__] it's a mile and a
half down the street not three Towns
over or I'm leaving Maryland and going
to Minnesota you know it's like I'm g go
right there where you have a chance to
run into them at the grocery store at
anything in traffic so strange yeah it's
wild so your dad's like I'm out yep and
then but doesn't want to see you or is
this your choice so I don't I mean it
had to have been his choice I would
imagine but then then what he would do
you don't remember your mom ever like
you're not going over
protective reasons no it was nothing
like that um then my dad around the
holidays would always find a woman to
court and really woo her and then she
would end up buying us the big ticket
items for Christmas n he hustled these
ladies like that yeah like give me what
do you remember getting so I got a
TV your dad hustled a woman in I got a
TV I got a stereo you know when DV when
CDs you know were at their prime it was
like the speakers the sub like all this
stuff um and how do you know they're
getting it cuz he is he not working or
like because he he would say that like
this one lady denal was her name denil
pretty cool name it is I've never met a
denal I'll tell you something as a young
man I'm a teenager and I'm like she's
she good looking and then I'd go to his
apartment to un unwrap these gifts that
he didn't buy and then there's like
candles burnt down that the wax is over
the table and you're like well I know
what this is for this is [__]
disgusting don't bring me to this house
of sin to give me this Christmas present
and then uh I'll get a TV and he'll be
like well just so you know you know
denil pitched in on this and then you'd
see her roll her eyes and you're like
okay I know exactly what's happening
right now and then you'd see him again
in like February or something and' be
like where's denal like ah didn't work
out that never does
November to January worked out for you
yeah November to January is about when
is that right you would notice that
pattern yep and they would all get you
something always always and it was
always big ticket yeah man that's a good
little hustle your dad got going on
that's pretty slick and and is he in
touch with your mom at all do you don't
they don't ever communicate no he he
left her in
bankruptcy and oh [__] I mean he was he
was a real Gambler so I didn't know oh
is that right I didn't know to the
extent it was alcohol drugs
gambling when I was in sixth grade I um
came home from school and my dad was
home which is weird he was a liquor
salesman which is like pretty good for
an alcoholic right just right hey here's
a box of stuff for you to ruin your life
with and so I got home and he had a VHS
tape in he goes you got to come down
here and watch this so I don't really
know what I'm watching but it is a man
who's doing standup comedy
but he's got a bucket on his head and
he's doing impersonations and I was like
all right he goes I work with this guy
he's so funny last night I brought him
down to Minneapolis and we got this tape
at Scott Hansen's comedy Galler and uh
I'm going to manage him and so your
dad's going into management now holy
[__] what an announcement my dad my
dad's saying was I don't want a white
picked fence I want white pill
that was his big wow that was his saying
and then he came up with these ideas of
like here's what we're going to do we're
going to put an ad in the paper and then
people are going to give us money to go
down to Minneapolis to buy their
Christmas presents for them because they
don't want to go down there I'm like
everyone wants to go down there this is
going to not be good at all and so he
got like two offers lost money on the
deal because of gas like all this stuff
he was always trying to you know get
rich quick and
so um he shows me this say he's going to
manage this guy start picking stuff out
start you know what I know you want
these jeans that we can't afford we're
going to get them like all this stuff so
cut two I am now a stand-up
comedian all this P time has passed I've
heard stories about my dad all this
stuff and um I'm working with this guy
and at the end of his set he puts a
[__] bucket on his head and I go
I've seen this before and I start
thinking and it is the dude from the
tape and so afterwards and by the way
I'm I'm headlining the show he's opening
and so I go do you know Steve Daniels
and he was like yeah I used to work with
him I go that's my dad he showed me a
tape of you when I was in sixth grade
not realizing how big of a slap in the
face that is it's like remember when you
were doing this when I was in sixth
grade I'm better at it now you know such
a how old were you [__] move I
probably
28 for 22 years this dude's closer has
been a bucket on his head give imagine
that's in your Rider I need a bucket at
the club I ain't travel with a bucket so
you guys sell beer by the bucket right
okay leave the beer out of one of them
I'm going to need the [__] out 22 years
with the bucket closer so he's real mad
oh so he he did get offended by he
terribly offended Y and uh wh which part
I'm more offended you're closing with a
bucket on your for two decades so uh
then then he ends up coming around on
the
weekend and he goes uh I suppose he got
some questions about your old man and I
go no I go well I mean you want to tell
me some stories so my
dad let me pause this story because I
got to tell you something else I was
just about to ask you yeah cuz there
seems to be like you're not talking to
your father so oh yeah I'm not talking
to my father at this point he's he's out
of my life for a while at what age does
that happen um the last time I saw my my
dad was
26 till now till yeah cuz well I well I
think he's dead all right we're going to
circle back we're going to circle this
going to be one talk one of these
Quinton Tarantino movies he was still
dating some hot ladies at Christmas and
now he's gone yeah all right we'll come
back so that like when he was dating the
hot lades of Christmas I was in high
school still okay so
um when my dad would come home on payday
he would have one of two things in his
hand he would have crab legs or he would
have the chicken chow in that two
sectioned can where the top you'd break
the little film and then the top would
be the gravy and the meat and the
bottoms everything else and so if he had
chicken chow I would send my sister
downstairs because it was about about to
be World War III right because it's like
that's the cheapest thing you can buy
right after R crab yeah and so you're
like well he doesn't have any money and
it's payday uh-oh so we'd go downstairs
and if it was crab legs it was like
[__] party central so I find out how
he's losing all of his money on payday
is he used to go into the bar after he'd
get his
check Cash's check by the way never put
knee away and he would make these bets
on something like a fly landing on the
bar wait he's not betting on sports on
the TV oh no no no he's he's betting
random people at the
bar he's like I'll give you 10 to one
odds 10 to one he throwing out on 50 so
it's 500 if he loses on which fly land
or if the fly lands on one of us if it
lands on you you get 500 lands on me I
get listen if you're making that bet you
better have wiped yourself down in [__]
or something to win this bet and he's
just losing constantly right and that at
one point this guy goes people were this
was I'm sorry I've never heard gu going
broke on those kind I have a a cousin
who went broke on get Sports gambling
not even sports that's what I'm saying
I've never heard of just throwing out
these bets like bet that guy uses a
pencil instead of a pen how much I'll
give you one on that exactly like those
kind of bets just going around and
pissing away your fortune that guy that
guy pulls a pen out of his pocket and
it's [__] chicken chow
dude I mean it's crazy to think about
I'm I'm a father I never even imagine
that [__] never never yeah so he's
telling me all these stories um that so
he tells me all the gambling stories and
stuff and I'm like okay this is starting
to make sense do you let him still do
spots the I I've never SE I haven't seen
him since that weekend oh okay I haven't
seen him since that weekend he just came
back to hang out he's not working with
you oh yeah he was working this is the
same weekend so the Thursday night is
when I said I know you and then Saturday
is when he finally tells me these
stories got it okay and so um I didn't
even heard of that guy until I was
golfing in the town where they worked as
liquor reps and I said uh they go what
do you do for a living I go I'm a
stand-up comedian they go oh do you know
so and so and I go that name sounds
familiar and they go uh bucket and I'm
like I do who the [__] but don't tell
him don't tell him I'm here [__] I
mean wild you probably heard of micro
doing but if not just know that all
sorts of people are micro doing to feel
healthier and perform better you know
that just right feeling when your body
and mind are really at peace like after
a workout or a nice long shower where
you're relaxed focused and a little
energized being in the zone well micro
do can help you get into that zone
easier and stay there longer for me half
a micro do gummy during the day helps me
stay centered and fresh it doesn't bog
me down which means I can get everything
done on my list they're even great at
night help you wind down be present in
the moment instead of worrying about
things from that day or about what's
coming up tomorrow all right to learn
more about micro doing THC go to micro
do.com and use code honeydew to get free
shipping and 30% off your first order
again that's micro do.com code honeydo
micro
do.com code honeydew for
30% off now let's get back to the D so
um so yeah so I got to know uh I got to
know some stories about my old man
through
him um if we go back two years before
that well let's okay let's go back to
when Dad you and Dad stop talking first
okay I'm 15 and I get confirmed at
Lutheran
Church and my mom always had on top of
the refrigerator there was a Bible and
my mom always had these um unique bills
us bills in there so it would be like um
one was printed with blue ink or one was
shifted a little you can see the lines
where they're supposed to be cut but it
was shifted so they're almost like error
cards when you collect baseball cards
yeah I know I think they're they're
worth money aren't they they're worth
more because there aren't any of those
right yeah and so one of them was uh a
dollar bill with both sides printed on
the same side and then the the other
side was blank and so oh okay not okay
right so you got the front and the back
back on the same side it didn't flip
clean yep yep okay and so um my my mom
has those in the Bible my Dad shows up
with a present must have not been
[__] anybody at that time cuz he had
to do it and it is a frame and I open it
and I'm thinking it's like going to be a
picture of a sports person or something
it is those bills that my mom had
collected when she was at the bank those
bills
framed your dad's stole your mom's bills
to give me framed them and gave them to
you for a Christmas present for a
confirmation present yeah get the [__]
out in front of your mom in front of her
she watched me open it did she just go
nuts she my mom is such a good woman
that she a good person that she just
took it all in stride but I could see in
her face her face dropped and um so
immediately as soon as he leaves I go I
don't want these here he is are yours
you can have them she goes no no this is
good this would be a good present for
you I go I'm not taking them she goes go
ahead and take them it's fine like okay
so I've never had it up I took them out
of the frame and just put them back you
know what they're worth you ever had
them no however that's got to be that
one that's got nothing on the back's got
to be worth a chunk I mean I don't know
anything about interesting you sound
like my dad at this point
because now fast forward I know this is
going all over the place but I'm 26 my
son is 2 years old he's never met my son
don't even know if he knows I have a son
but that Christmas he is calling on a
landline nonstop and so it's like it's
your dad it's your dad it's finally I go
what I haven't and I hadn't talked to
him
in I'll say five years at this point so
the I just want to ask the reason you
stopped communicating with him is
because he gave you this [__]
horrific gift the reason I stopped
communicating is is going to get crazy
the reason I stopped communicating with
him is because he had me unknowingly
help him steal a car to leave town to
avoid the
authorities dude we'll get there we'll
get there how much time you got you got
we got all day bro you were patient with
me I'm going to be patient with
you it's insane oh
okay so uh where am I at we're jumping
to 26
my son's two blah blah blah um he's
calling like crazy he's calling and I I
go what do you want and he goes I was
just at a Coin Show in Las Vegas that's
where he had moved Las Vegas and he goes
I was just at a coin show and I saw a
dime that had both sides printed on one
like indented on one and the other side
was flat and it went for Millions he
goes let me come get that bill and I'll
split it with you
and I'm like it's not yours you took it
once when it wasn't yours I'm not giving
it to you again this goes to my whatever
and he goes let me get it so he kept
calling I go here's a deal I go I hand
you this bill and PS you have a
two-year-old yeah that he's never seen
his grandson right let me come get it
doesn't mention it yeah right let me
come get the bill congrats how you doing
hey by the way just right in I was at a
coin show yeah that sounds like an
addict yeah I mean for sure you know all
that preon ation he's already had in his
head too and now I'm just spitting this
out and another thing like what another
we haven't T in 15 years fck you talking
about right so so I go you come get this
and then that's it I don't want to hear
from you again you're giving it to him
I'm gonna give you this as a as a deal
that you do not contact me again this is
and he's like okay okay all right his
own kid that feels good so he shows up
at my place this is when I'm the 10
years I did not live in Fergus Falls I
was about an hour south of Minneapolis
he shows up and he goes uh it's got this
pretty nice car and I go that's that's a
nice car and he goes yeah I went in to
get the loan and they must have thought
I was like a different Steve Daniels CU
they had the address was different all
that stuff but I let him think it and I
got the car I'm like yep I remember you
you know it's just like hey Dad you
you're the [__] worst of humanity cuz
now there's a Steve Daniels that has to
eat this this loan and explain
everything and whatever and so he comes
in and uh and he's like so what where is
it where's the bill and I go I'll give
it to you relax and I go Isaac this is
Steve Steve this is Isaac yeah because
then then he goes uh Isaac my son he
goes who's this man and he started to
say I'm your and I go he's just a guy he
is just a guy and I just stared at him
and he goes wow and I go well you
[__] got to earn it there's certain
things in the world you have to earn and
being a Grandpa's one of them right and
so he goes all right well I'll just take
that and get out of your hair and I go
no problem but first we're going to arm
wrestle because he used to make me arm
wrestle all the time and just [__]
Knuckles to table destroy me and I'm
like guess what [__] your son's been
your son's been lifting and he's in his
prime and I know this is probably really
catty and really small but I just
[__] all right let's go [__] over
the top oh I just I thought I was going
to pull his elbow right out of the joint
but how good that feel Phil felt pretty
good you know and what did he do what
was his response he goes oh oh I guess
you've been exercising huh like get the
[__] out of here so then I just gave him
the thing he split and that's the last
time I ever heard from him my sister had
heard from kep his word at least for
that yeah that's thing he kept his well
I think he died so pretty easy to do
yeah I see pretty easy to do he uh did a
me the clinic for a while oh you do know
that much well he had so his sister kind
of had been in contact with him and told
us afterwards but I guess he got in a
car accident or something and my sister
knew some of it I didn't want to I
didn't give a [__] I didn't need to know
any of it cuz like I'm concentrating
on like shifting this two generations of
bad dads I'm concentrating on fixing
that so I don't need you to be around
that kind of [__] but you were saying
your sister had she maybe heard from or
something in the time you didn't she had
heard from him um yeah a couple times
cuz she went to um she went to rehab as
well and so she had heard from him in
there and he he called her and he's like
well I heard from your Aunt that you're
in rehab he goes what are you doing he
like how are you being Mis judgmental
not how are you doing what are you doing
yeah so I will tell you this you get and
and this is going to sound like I'm make
excuses but I really believe this you
get drugs alcohol financial problems
from a gambling
addiction that can turn a good person
into a real pile of [__] really quickly
I do remember my old man when it would
snow he would drive around with me and
we would find people that were stuck and
he would we'd get out he'd bring a
shovel we'd get out and we'd push him
out so there was goodness there but I
think that that gets wiped out once you
know the disease spiraling down
absolutely and that's true with Dix he's
hitting them alcohol gam I mean drugs
like this is this is you're not long on
this planet with that lifestyle at all
yeah and I don't joke about drinking and
driving that much but he had eight DUIs
and eight eight of them and his eighth
one he didn't have a
license could he could he talks somebody
into giving him uh a a a rental place
into giving him a van he moves
everything out of the van takes the
seats out that are there and he puts in
a card table and like a disco ball he
wasn't wasn't allowed in bars so he's
like wasn't drive around and have my own
bar so he's driving a group of people
around partying in this van and he gets
nailed for his eth DUI that's pretty
[__] legendary that's how they pull
him over pretty legendary yeah it was a
full page spread in the paper I was a
sophomore spot yeah
yeah yeah it got in the paper and
everything I was a sophomore in high
school that's crazy and I was a smartass
because you're just dealing with
everything by
deflecting and a couple of the seniors
made a bunch of uh made a bunch of
copies of the article and for morning
football practice it was plastered all
over the locker room and I was likez
Jesus Christ they do that really do and
I had a geometry teacher Mr Pearson who
was always really strict with me because
I was a smartass but that day he came
over as I was doing my work in class put
his hand on my shoulder gave it one
little squeeze and then that was it just
that silent little how about that yeah
doesn't isn't it funny that just one
little thing like that could really
[__] change [__] about a person too
yeah you got this thing going on with
your dad and then you got that moment
right there with that dude
and he was after that moment like you
know I'd get offered Twins tickets or
Vikings tickets or whatever just because
of the job and I I couldn't go he was
always my first call hell yeah just like
hey man if you want to go go for it
without a squeeze did he ever take you
up on it oh yeah [__] yeah dude I love
that go back to telling me about why you
stopped talking to your dad we didn't
tell that story you said the car oh the
car oh yeah all right so I'm
21 I get a car which by the way took me
a very long time because when I was in
high school my dad had stolen my
identity to get electric phone an
apartment when do you find that out
though when I try to get electric phone
apartments and everyone's like [__] you
dude you owe us money already and I'm
like that's impossible I lived with my
mom so she had to write a letter I had
to have witness that said I lived with
her all this stuff and so finally get
that taken care of and I get a car and
it starts acting up to it's a Ed car two
days after I get it starts acting up so
I bring it back to the dealership and
they go all right there's a uh an engine
issue and I'm like should you have told
me that before I bought it so then they
have to rebuild the engine and they go
we'll give you a rental car like all
right no problem hadn't heard from my
dad for a long time he's living in Fargo
North Dakota which is about an hour away
from Fergus Falls and he goes somehow
he's just in the network of my family
and knows stuff and he goes hey I heard
you got a car I'm like yep he goes yeah
but the engine problem right you got a
rental car I'm like I do and he goes
well listen I know I haven't talked in a
while I would love it if you and your
sister could come up and go to
launch okay you know cuz you always it's
your dad so you always want to give him
that chance to make things right and he
just didn't have it in him so we go to
lunch and he goes your sister's with you
too sister's with me and uh he goes oh I
got to put my stuff in your car do you
mind and I was like I guess and he goes
out and he's gone for I'm GNA guess 20
minutes I was like did you get lost yeah
wow couldn't find it okay so comes back
still has his
bag then he calls
me maybe two weeks later and he goes you
still have that rental car I'm like no I
gave it back because my car got fixed
and he goes all right I need you to come
get me in Fargo okay well he had he had
just done a little bit of jail time for
writing bad checks but he was going to
go to prison and he's like I won't last
in prison he knew it and so I didn't
know this until I drove him all the way
back from Fargo to Fergus Falls anytime
I would go one mile over the speed limit
1 m per hour he'd be like slow down like
okay you know not knowing what's going
on
so I go where do you want to go he goes
bring me to uh more Ford and I go all
right so we go in there and he goes all
right drive around and find your rental
car I'm like what are you talking about
during lunch he had taken my keys and
made a copy of the key because he knew
this whole thing was a scam for him to
be able to get into that rental car and
and run away from the cops so we're I
finally find out that 20 minutes or
whatever he's gone he was getting a copy
of the key yeah come on come to lunch
with your old man drive 2hour round trip
okay so now he tells you to find the
rental car so find the rental car he
gets out he takes uh I remember this
because i' never seen it before he takes
his what the odds that it's still there
anyone else could have rented that car
well I I think it's um oh like one of
their one of their used cars they just a
little loner yeah gotcha so he use takes
his driver's license and scrapes it cuz
there's frost on the windshield and I
remember that I'm like o all right I
I'll keep
that with with a dab like that it is not
often you go all right I'm this is a
learning moment right so I I keep that
he gets in the car I'm like how do you
have keys he goes ah so I made a copy of
the key you know I can't go to prison I
got to get out of here he goes follow me
out of town so I follow him out of town
and I get out of the car he drives that
the car right off the lot right off the
lot no one says anything no oh no no no
it's night time oh okay it's closed it's
been closed for a while all right so we
take off and I'm thinking like oh he
wants me to follow him out of town give
me a hug obviously because he's taken
off he's like I I get out of my car and
he goes get back in your car so I roll
the window down he's like do you see
anybody behind you I'm like no he goes
all right I'm out of here I go oh I go
why did I follow you out here and he
goes well just one car in front of me
and a cop if that and I was like
okay you're running [__] interference
you know how some parents they like uh
back when there were remote controls and
they before remote controls and they
were like hey go turn the channel mhm
that's what some parents use their kids
for not me I hit the jackpot my dad used
me to uh steal a car and then run
interference on a potential
cop so you could get out of town is that
literally the last time you saw him
until the building until the 20 until I
was 26 that's how left and then you
don't hear from till the bills do you
know if that bill is worth anything I
have no clue I mean for all I know my
dad is alive and [__] living in a
mansion somewhere on that bill but good
I mean matter me DB Cooper in that [__]
bro so I want to talk to you about um
well you have two kids right two yep and
only the oldest met your father your
youngest has never met your dad right
and do you tell do you still tell them
story like are you honest about your dad
they got to ask do you have pictures of
them around or anything like that they
have seen pictures so it was funny we're
going through a picture album and then
there's a a
photocopied um piece of paper and there
there's a driver's license that has my
dad's picture on it and then a bunch of
credit cards and this was sent to my mom
by the uh um what's it called
child what do you have to pay for child
child yeah Jesus Christ he was supposed
to be paying child support so like a
child support collection person found
out listen to this piece of
[__] you you haven't even heard the
worst of it that's what's crazy I love
it I mean I don't love it for you but I
can't believe there's another one he's
already ruined your credit he's got your
run interal police this isn't even about
me he had a classmate that after
graduation died in a motorcycle accident
he called their family to find out to to
tell them you guys are supposed to be
getting benefits what's his social
security number stole his identity no
yeah and had so it's Thomas rice had his
ID said Thomas rice all his credit cards
and so they had found him oh that's what
your mom got yeah she got this
under Thomas rice not and then you
looked at when he went in to get the um
to get the license and it was June 19th
which is my dad's real birthday but then
the birthday on there was Thomas Rice's
birthday so he had all the other
information so once he got his his
social security number he was able to
become Thomas rice I guess he ended up
getting a really good job in Las Vegas
you know the people that offer you uh
vacation packages mhm he was that guy
and he worked his way up to making over
six figures a year and still Tommy rice
is
but figes 150g for Tommy
R and he still [__] it up how cuz he's
in Vegas ging away it's so crazy to me
it's like you have stolen a dead
person's identity was he getting those
benefits too was he [__] cashing
those benefits I don't think there were
benefits so so
he Social Security numbers he told them
there were there were what a piece of
[__] no [__] I mean you're talking about
parents that have lost a child and now
they're waiting on benefits the only
possible Speck of sunlight in this
situation and it's benefits that never
come and their sons living out in Las
Vegas selling vacation packages on paper
yeah their new son their new kid God
damn how do you find that out cuz your
mom showed you like how do you guys all
together because there was a private
investigator that was looking for him
for child support that went out and
found out that this person on paper this
Thomas rice my dad was
making six figures at this company and
then maybe that's what spooked him and
then maybe that's why he took off so I I
man I don't know all of it but I mean
what Fu holy [__] dude that's wild how
do you even keep all that together as
far as what do you mean all these
stories and stuff like and then you're
like yeah you seem very even killed
about like yeah I'll come out and meet
you yeah cuz you're always wanting to
give a chance right so what was it that
shifted in you personally finally where
you're like [__] this I think it was
having a kid yeah that's what I wanted
to ask you next about the father you
want to be yeah having a kid it was like
all right listen we're 0 for two the
last two generations it's time to like
that's time to correct that completely
shift it and your mom was understanding
about not introducing the kids to your
dad at all or barely yeah I mean I don't
I think but you also seemed like you
were okay with it you said you had to
earn it you would like you ever shut the
door and said [__] off no and he just
never took the opportunity no yeah my my
mom was always supportive whatever we
wanted to do in that realm she was like
yeah that's your choice that's what you
do all right so what was it you said you
again you took from your dad you're like
I'm gonna take that what was it oh he
had a he scraped off the windshield with
his driver's license right okay other
thing are there any other things you I
know you well you did spend 15 years so
there any similar he taught me how to
shoot hoops he taught me how to throw he
taught me like a lot of sports stuff
that I still use today that I I
appreciate what about and parenting
stuff anything
um yeah I suppose I suppose being funny
with your kid like being goofy with your
kids but also I'm the dad I mean you
know I've never ever grabbed my kid's
arm or under the chin or anything like
that um but yeah grabbing a neck and
putting you against a wall to let you
know like hey yeah and I I forgot about
that until my mom and sister brought it
up oh I thought it was when the chick
choked you no no no cuz they brought it
up when I was like early 20s or
something and uh and they we saw
something like that happen and I and I
got up to go deal with the guy that did
it to the kid and I go God damn I don't
know what got into me and they're like
you don't and I'm like I don't know what
you're and then they told me they're
like that's how he used to
always do that to you to shut you up and
I'm like oh okay I must I must have
choked it down pretty hard how was he
with your sister a lot better very
protective but he's still you know
absent everything manipulative and all
that stuff
so I had
uh I had um gotten in big trouble once
for stealing all my sister's money out
of her piggy bag bank and wasn't me but
it was him oh no [__] and then I
collected all this money I had a paper
route and I collected all this money
where I had to give most of that money
to the actual Paper Company the
newspaper company and I had it all in
this Incredible Hulk lunchbox gone and
I'm like I know I don't care if you
stole it but a lot of that wasn't mine
now I have to pay you stole my money now
I have to pay back yeah for the rest of
this [__] that's wild he would steal
that [__] it was crazy it was crazy I'm
not a violent person but I do think I'd
punch him in the face I was going to ask
you if he called you today if he was
alive and said he'd like to see you
would you say yeah I think so would you
punch him uh I don't think so but I mean
because he's he's old man right that's
the thing I talk to Dr Drew about that
he goes look you at some point even
though you have shitty parents you got
to just let it go because if you don't
then you look like the younger person
badgering this old person that just VIs
usually looks feeble and everything you
become this [__] going after that
person that person that old little [__]
isn't the person that did all that [__]
to you back then you know what I mean
not now they're not yeah oh I I will I
will tell you that um I struggled with
forgiveness for so long and then after I
got a divorce I realized forgiveness has
nothing to do with the other person yeah
nothing it is all about you just [__]
letting go and cooling it and having a
better life so
yeah I didn't learn that till I was in
my God my mid-30s maybe it was and and
someone said to me like you you can't
forgive someone who isn't asking for
forgiveness right if if I'm not coming
to you and saying I'm sorry please
forgive me right the what forgiveness
you get I I don't I don't want that I
ain't asking for that it is for yourself
it's all for yourself I didn't realize
either I'm like oh I forgave this person
so and then nothing [__] changed
right you know it was my mom nothing
changed right except for some words I
said and it was thank you very much and
that's it and nothing changed Y and then
I was like oh she didn't we want that I
wanted that yep I wanted that for me
next day bro next day you laugh I go to
a Dodger game and a [__] one of the
players throws a ball out left hand up
boom grab it caught a ball I was like
I've never caught a ball at a [__]
game before [__] things are going to
turn around my mom didn't change one
[__] bit
I turned around I gave that ball to a
little girl in the crowd I go here you
go she had a little Dodger cap here you
go and they were like thank you so much
I'm like you're welcome things gonna be
good with my
mom
n didn't change for one bit oh [__]
that's
great dude thank you for doing this I
really thanks for having me on this of
course this has been long overdue man
it's been great to sit down and who
doesn't want to go back and revisit
[__] tragedy bro I'm tired of
everybody's Instagrams I want to hear
all your low lights I love it's like
blues for me you know what I mean that
it's those I I always grew up my dad
introduced me to blues and I loved those
songs where like these people could take
the worst [__] thing about something
put it in music and then you're over
there cheering for it like yeah [__]
yeah make me feel good also makes you
feel like you're not alone you know oh I
sit and listen to some I there's
definitely people out there that think
they have a shitty dad and after this
episode they gon be like call they're G
call their dad and tell them they're
sorry
and I'm not I'm not woe as me because
listen I can tell I had a really good
life my mom you know I I always say that
with both your parents you get a total
of 100 points and it just matters on
which the thing is and my mom was like
98 points yeah I mean you can't get much
better than that right I've had
therapists tell me too the truth is that
you just need one you truly just need
one person who loves you and believes in
you and cares about you and if you got
one you're good yep still waiting bro um
all right your first could be me could
be you maybe we'll see how you answer
this question okay your first time here
I I'd mentioned to you before we
recorded advice you'd give to your
16-year-old self so I'm curious because
15's a pivotal moment for you with your
dad at least for the first chunk you
stop talking to 15 right yeah 15 to 26
and your dad leaves yeah what advice
would you give 16-year-old Chad Daniels
um I would
say for every
thing every time you have one of those
thoughts where it's like oh [__] life
sucks you got to immediately find two
things that make you happy [__] yeah
that way at the end of the day you're
always always plus you know yeah that's
great man nobody's ever said anything
like that do you have you trained
yourself to that when you think
something negative you try to positive
hit two more yeah so when I got divorced
I went through some therapy and I was
out in the woods and I told my therapist
local guy I was like like I saw a deer
today out in the woods and he's like
yeah that's where they live I go well
I've never seen one and he goes this
time wait growing up in Minnesota no I'd
always seen them but not on this
particular walk gotta and so CU I'd walk
every day just to gather my thoughts and
then he goes you know what this time
there's a thing called a seatan watch
where named after a guy that invented it
Satan you sit down and then after 15 and
you're very still and after 15 minutes
look around Nature has come back after
the noise and so I start looking around
and I bet you I saw 20 deer that day no
[__] and I and he so he was like it's
it's what you look for it's the stuff
that you look for that you're going to
see so and that includes the negative
[__] too if you're always looking for
problems you're going to find you're
programming your your mind is a computer
what program do you want to run in your
computer you know so I tell my kids
always look for that and then I tell my
kids uh don't borrow worry from around
the bend right it's like if you're going
to spend three days worrying about that
[__] why not just wait till it happens
then you've at least had three extra
days of not worrying it's going to
happen it's going to happen but dude
thank you for doing this for real for
great episode dude this is fun um
promote everything one more time please
plug it all okay Dad if you're out
[Laughter]
there you know where to find me that
Chad Daniels on
socials um chadd danels dcom tour I mean
there's a bunch of stuff just go to Chad
daniels.com there's a bunch of stuff on
there and I have a special coming out
it's a mixed reviews it's already on
YouTube I did two specials in one night
uh this one is the first one out next
one will be out pretty soon so pretty
excited about that because I did each of
them is one take and it's just pretty
much as it as it was so I left I I
almost have a stroke on stage trying to
remember the a flight from where I was
going um and I couldn't remember it and
I said the wrong thing and it ended up
being Town's 40 minutes apart driving so
you'd never take a flight and then I
just had a meltdown on stage and I just
left it all you yeah so I think it's
it's very fun great yeah good for you
man thank you again as always Ryan
sickler on all social media Ryan sar.com
we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week
[Music]
a